bustling Japan one of the most crowded
places on Earth is unique in Asia
Japan is industrial Urban literate
prosperous Japan is a Modern Nation
will examine how the people of this
nation
without enough land to supply all of its
need without enough food though its
farmers are among the most successful on
the globe with too few natural resources
for its burgeoning Industries
with some of the world's largest and
fastest growing cities
how the people of this crowded island
nation solve the Menace of runaway
population
and so gave themselves the rewards of
mid-20th century life
[Music]
Japan is the first Asian Nation to do so
in this Century the only Asian Nation to
do so and the only nation in history to
do so in such a short period of time
for many reasons it was imperative for
the Japanese people to limit their
population growth rate
[Music]
Japan's 98 million people are packed
into a narrow 1500 mile string of
islands
an area the size of California
less than five percent of the land mass
of the United States
for a population half as large as this
country's
because there is little land for
cultivation Japan has always turned to
the Sea for almost all of its protein
Japanese fishermen following ancient
ways fish Coastal and domestic waters
for most of their massive cats
[Applause]
for the rest modern Factory ships go
thousands of miles processing their Hall
as it is brought aboard
foreign
cannot Supply this populist nation's
total needs to survive Japan must
exploit every natural Advantage its
Hills its mountains its Plains its
valleys its rivers
with only 15 percent of the land fit for
cultivation even the rugged hillsides
soil most other nations would not Farm
must be used
foreign
s are used for Rice the precious
Mainstay of the Japanese people
intensive cultivation of very small
wheat farms and heavy use of chemicals
brings the Japanese farmer higher yields
per acre than his American counterpart
however scarcity of land keeps Japanese
production far below population needs
twenty percent of Japan's food still
must be imported
each year seven hundred thousand men
women and children replaced by
mechanization and lured by The Promise
of Greater reward flow to the cities
migration from the farm to the city is
one of the marks of a heavily
industrialized Society
Tokyo the largest and most chaotic
sprawl in history now has more than 10
million people
and still they come nearly 60 000 each
month choking cities in search of a
place in the country's burgeoning
Industries
it is Japan's enormous industrial
progress combined with population
control that keeps our economic growth
far ahead of population increases
nowhere is Japan's economic power more
apparent than in Shipbuilding
foreign foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Japan's vessels are giant tankers bigger
than aircraft carriers the largest
vessels ever made by man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
sophisticated Industries involving
Precision manufacture by skilled and
educated workers have created much of
the industrial success
Japan has been able to compete as an
industrial power largely because her
labor force is almost 100 percent
literate one of the highest literacy
rates in the world with immense
technical skills
however for a major industrial Giant
Japan has remarkably poor natural
resources
sixty percent of its industrial
materials comes from foreign points
[Applause]
[Music]
to succeed Japanese industry must export
s increasing three times the world
average Japanese trade is leading the
nation to new prosperity
[Music]
productivity has been rising sharply as
have earnings
while still low by U.S standards per
capita income has doubled in the last
decade it is by far the highest in Asia
National wealth is the greatest in
Japanese history
[Music]
[Applause]
older people have accepted the fruits of
the post-war years but have been slow to
reconcile themselves to the accompanying
social changes
[Applause]
the shattering effects of this Urban
Society should that have been totally
unexpected since the Japanese have been
building in this direction or nearly a
century
and the story of Japan's population
control Miracle as even earlier
beginnings
under a rigidly fixed social order there
were 18 million people in this island
nation when the Tokugawa shogunate was
established in 1603 peasants were
important the agricultural economy
rested on them
priests
and the Very powerful Samurai were atop
the feudal social order
Merchants Traders and bankers were
considered unproductive and useless
citizens
by the 1630s fear of European colonizers
turned the nation inward
under government encouragement
agriculture the continuing basis of the
economy expanded
and the population increased
from 18 million at the start of the 17th
century to about 30 million in the
middle of the 18th an increase of 75
percent in 150 years
[Music]
isolated limited land-hungry
agricultural Nation had reached its
population limit
it could support only about 30 million
people
the birth rate was high
but the traditional levelers poverty
malnutrition famine disease kept the
death rate high
and people found other ways to balance
population
often younger Sons were discouraged from
marrying
some used folk methods of contraception
infanticide was common
upper classes used abortion
the traditional use of abortion as a
legitimate and moral method of family
control has assisted in Japan's control
of modern population growth
during the 18th and 19th centuries the
merchants gained greater control over
the economy especially in the cities
Dutch Traders brought news of the
Industrial Revolution and of the great
political and scientific changes in the
West
in 1853 Commodore Matthew Perry demanded
and received a limited treaty
more ambitious treaty calling for trade
was signed in 1858
Japan's doors open
in the last century of Tokugawa rule the
population had stabilized itself at 30
million people
Western strength pointed up the weakness
of the Tokugawa regime
[Music]
the shogunate slowly crumbled
in 1868 the enthronement of the young
Emperor Meiji began a 44-year Reign that
would carry Japan to world power
his advisors were impressed by Western
military strength
his Empress gave attention to the
farmers
the government leaned heavily on the
peasant for tax revenues
[Music]
she supported the new policy of
compulsory education
Japan would soon need a literate
Workforce
the Western world became Japan's School
[Applause]
Japan was becoming a modern industrial
state
the government supported industrial
expansion developed new systems of
transportation and Communications
encouraged ever-increasing trade as a
result
better farming increased Food Supplies
modern medicine cut the death rate
standards of living improved
what had been a stabilized population by
1898 zoomed up 10 million a 33 percent
increase in 30 years
[Music]
Japan lacked almost every necessary
resource to meet the needs of the
growing population the militarist said
they had the answer expand
[Applause]
Formosa and the pescadori
[Applause]
[Music]
or Korea
a foothold in North China
for the first time but not the last
population pleasure was an excuse for
military conquest
in spite of her fast-moving armies
Japan's population pressures kept
increasing by 1920 her population was 60
million a 100 percent increase in 50
years
The militarists Wanted still more
territory
[Music]
31 led to a Japanese gamble for the
whole Asian Pacific area
the American Fleet at Pearl Harbor was
the only obstacle
[Music]
in six months beginning in 1941 where
fantastically successful
Japanese armies overran the Philippines
Hong Kong Malaya Singapore Burma the
Dutch East Indies strategic Islands from
Guadalcanal in the South Pacific to the
aleutians in the North
for a moment the Japanese empire was one
of the largest in history
but the tide turned in 1942 allied
forces began pushing back finally
bringing the war to Japan itself
thrown back on its own ruined Islands
threatened with famine the nation was
crushed and demoralized
[Music]
for the first time in history Japan was
occupied by a foreign army the people
expected a Vengeance that never came
[Music]
in those desperate years the conquerors
supplied the margin of survival
to aggravate the problem more than six
million troops and civilians returned
a massive Baby Boom followed
the emperor renounced any claim to
personal Divinity the old order was gone
remaining was a demoralized and
conquered Nation the skeleton of what
had been a mighty industrial Giant and a
frightening population problem
[Music]
in the post-war Baby Boom the birth rate
soared while peace and Medicine cut the
death rate to new lows
yearly population growth tripled from
half a million in 1946 to a million and
a half in 1947.
but in 1948 and 1949 the birth rate
dropped slightly then sharply in the 50s
and by 1957 the birth rate was half out
of 10 years before
in a single decade the Japanese people
completed their demographic transition
the changeover from the high birth and
death rates of the past to the low birth
and death rates which characterize
today's modern Nations how had they done
it
the heart of the answer lies in the
deeply personal decision of parents to
limit the size of their families
there were other catalysts under the
leadership of general Douglas
MacArthur's sweeping programs of social
political and economic reform were
instituted in the first post-war years
drastic land redistribution programs led
to remarkable increases in food
production
the people became Sovereign over their
government
women had the right to vote legal
equality and equal opportunities in
education
[Music]
as a result women today enjoy a new
Independence and are able to pursue
education and careers before marrying
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
age at marriage for women is almost 25
nearly 10 years higher than in India
later marriages cut years from a woman's
child bearing life
because of the extensive educational
demands made upon Japanese men the
average age for men at marriage is 27.
foreign
foreign
[Music]
newly married couples are not anxious to
give up participation in Japan's good
life
a participation built around two
salaries in a marriage's beginning
from tradition newlyweds strive to have
the privacy of their own apartment
the longings of their choice
[Music]
couples with a new sense of Independence
delay having children
often until the husband is in a sound
enough financial position to guarantee
continuing involvement in the good life
cutting additional years from a woman's
child-bearing potential
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Japanese parents themselves well
educated know the importance of an
education in an industrialized Society
they also realize that in such a society
children are an economic burden for many
years
[Music]
with the growth of a more humanistic
approach to life children have attained
a great deal of value as individuals
[Music]
[Applause]
even little girls
once past Elementary School age children
begin involvement in one of the world's
most competitive Educational Systems
[Applause]
although the great majority of Japanese
children complete High School acceptance
to further education is not guaranteed
because of the great numbers who want to
continue and the very high standards set
for entrance into higher education
but Japanese youngsters know the value
of higher education in an industrialized
society and many of them like this boy
attend special cram schools in an effort
to meet academic requirements and to
pass entrance examinations
that education is essential to the
well-being of an industrialized nation
is apparent to Japanese parents as a
result the necessity of adequate
education for children and its costs are
an important factor in controlling
family size
foreign
post-war Industrial Development has been
phenomenal
pushing the economy Upward at the
highest rates of any advanced Nation
and since the war industrialists have
been taking a deep interest in fertility
control as a part of industry-sponsored
programs Health and Welfare Specialists
go to workers homes
practical nurses bring advice on Child
Care and Family Health
thank you
some industry-sponsored programs even
show wives how to shop more economically
gradually these programs break down
shyness until at neighborhood meetings
birth control instruction begins hear
wives or urge to substitute
contraception for abortion
as a result the National Abortion rate
is on the decline
though with almost a million abortions
each year it is still one of Japan's
most common ways to prevent birth
[Music]
foreign
contraception practices fail Japanese
women can discuss abortion with a
qualified doctor
since abortion is traditional people
have no moral or religious qualms about
its use
the government discusses it openly in
magazines newspapers and films
as this government film shows there were
often distressing results in the rapidly
Rising number of illegal abortions in
the desperate post-war years
foreign
[Music]
therefore passed the Eugenics protection
law making the best modern medical
techniques available to women who for
economic or medical reasons want an
abortion
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
we're done
offense today this young woman can find
sympathetic attention from a doctor who
promotes contraception as a substitute
for abortion the doctor explains the
facts of abortion
she may even advise this woman to have
her baby on emotional grounds
the doctor has helped the couple
understand their problem
their decision can be the most important
of their young lives a child will
certainly change their way of life
a child will mean loss of the wife's
income
loss of their apartment loss of their
new freedoms and an eventual return to
living with their parents so
[Applause]
because
[Applause]
foreign
is difficult
[Music]
the literate Japanese people are aware
of the new problems their highly mobile
industrial and urban Society is
presenting
and they are as aware of the
difficulties of rearing large families
in such a society
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
by interested industrialists by a wise
government and by their own educated
choices they are deciding to keep
families small
in China India indeed almost across the
globe population is expected to double
by the end of this century
not in Japan
where births are below long-term
replacement needs
foreign
not inhibited by religious or moral
restrictions
a people acting in its own interest and
the interest of its children can bring
about population control
and can do so in a relatively short
period of time
the results of Japan's answer are
greater opportunities for the individual
and a fuller life for everyone
thank you
[Music]
this is net the national educational
television network
foreign